salut bonjour bonjour j'ai une
question légèrement différente pouvez-vous dire mon nom
non je suis désolé
j'essaie de faire faire deadpool
depuis 11 ans, c'est la plus longue
relation que j'aie jamais eue en
studio, je n'ai jamais appuyé sur la gâchette,
ils ne feraient jamais le film et
ce n'est que lorsque nos images de test ont été divulguées
accidentellement sur Internet et  les fans l'ont juste
poussé par dessus bord ils ont fait une telle
puanteur et ils ont fait un tel rugissement que le
studio ne pouvait plus l'ignorer et euh
ils ont dit oui je veux dire ils nous ont donné le
feu vert et c'était juste le meilleur jour
de ma vie  donc je veux dire que la naissance de ma
fille a été le meilleur jour de ma vie
vous pensez probablement que c'était un
film de super-héros mais ce gars en costume
vient de transformer cet autre gars en un kebab
surprise c'est un autre type d'
histoire de super-héros
Deadpool est venu  environ pour m  e en 2005, un
directeur de studio a dit que vous étiez Deadpool
et j'ai dit que je ne savais pas qui était Deadpool
et il m'a envoyé en cadeau
toutes ces bandes dessinées et je les ai lues et
je suis tombé amoureux de
tout mais je pense  la principale chose que
j'aime le plus à propos de Deadpool, c'est que lorsque
vous regardez le film et que j'ai regardé le
film en tant que fan de Deadpool, on a l'
impression que Deadpool est fan, vous savez,
c'est qu'il dit et fait les choses
que nous souhaitons tous pouvoir  dire et
faire dans un film de bande dessinée Fox a dit d'accord
allez faire de votre film Deadpool faire de votre
note nos morts quand nous verrons si
quelqu'un veut le voir, nous ne savons pas mais
nous ne vous donnons pas le budget x-men
nous  Je vous donne un budget plus petit, ils
nous ont donné ce qui est normalement sur la plupart des films,
c'est le budget de la cocaïne qu'ils nous ont donné
juste pour faire tout notre film, donc
nous avons vraiment dû étirer le dollar
et l'une des grandes choses était d'avoir
Tim Miller  en tant que directeur qui est un
artiste d'effets visuels, il possède une société d'
effets visuels  mpany donc il a fait en sorte que ce film ait l'
air aussi gros que les Avengers ou tout autre
film, mais sur une fraction du
coût, donc nous avons eu beaucoup de CGI beaucoup
pour notre argent alors que normalement vous savez que
ce serait beaucoup plus cher  ici
la musique
[Musique]
attends j'ai laissé le poêle allumé bien le
costume est assez intense c'est comme porter
un gros préservatif corps rouge toute la journée et c'est
environ vingt ou trente minutes pour l'enfiler
c'est environ vingt ou trente minutes
pour pisser  J'en suis tombé amoureux
à la fin du film en fait
à la fin du dernier jour de tournage j'ai
quitté le plateau en portant le costume
nous sommes Kim en dessous de ce stand je n'ai pas le
temps pour ta piscine x-men  Colossus, en
plus de personne ne se blesse, ce type
était là-haut avant que nous arrivions ici, le fait
qu'il n'ait pas été fait il y a onze ans
est en fait une bonne chose parce qu'en ce
moment, nous nous tenons au sommet de cette
supernova de super-héros, il y a tellement de
films de super-héros  en ce moment et
Deadpool ne pouvait pas arriver à un meilleur moment  e
je pense donc je suis vraiment heureux que ça atterrisse
maintenant alors dommage le mec qui la presse
dans le sexe de bal
j'aimerais pouvoir j'aime ça
adopter vous les gars aimez être mes enfants
vous à ma poitrine bien sûr faisons ça
c'est la fête  sur ouais non sérieusement je
voudrais savoir sérieusement je ne vais pas